all right Raymond the Biden campaign is
kicking into high gear
woooo well it would be considered
sleepwalking for any other campaign
Laura but for the president this is a
big swing he went to Vegas this weekend
and made his pitch and it was Viva Los
craigan Kraken Viva L Craigslist
[Music]
$60 billion that taxpayers don't have to
pay the Medicare to give to this I make
no apologize
no apologies roie way is taking away a
woman's right to choose before the
pandemic there were 750 48 or maybe
roughly
750 billionaires in America right right
right after I was elected I went to what
they call a G7 meeting it was in it was
in the south of England and I sat down
and I said America's back and mean from
Germany I mean from France looked at me
and said uh
said you
know what why how long you back
for Laura America's waiting for Joe
Biden to come back I mean this and by
the way franois Mand he's been dead
since 1996 Biden wasn't even vice
president then I guess he's going to
clear up the China trade imbalance by
talking to Chairman ma that's G to
happen any day
now Raymond um I there's a thing that he
does now I noticed I'm not sure what's
happening but there's a one eye closured
situation going on with Biden he does
like one eye like a Popeye deal I don't
know what that is it's hard enough for
him to see the teleprompter with both
eyes open as far as I could tell right
all right Raymond the bad news um for
the president though is that he's
continuing to lose um black voters
according to this latest Pew survey he's
lost 30 points with them since 2020 can
this be right yeah L and and black men
are souring on Biden as MSNBC discovered
this weekend when they spoke to rer
Benny The Butcher and others but the
president can rest easy kamla Harris hit
South Carolina this weekend to shore up
the black vote talk about what the black
vote means for the Biden Harris campaign
South Carolina what we have done to
Pardon tens of thousands of people for
simple marijuana possession nobody
should have to go to jail for smoking
weed
right or to to invest in and think about
how they can participate in the
manufacturing that we are funding here
in South Carolina as it relates to
electric
vehicles this woman so so Laura her
message her message for Black America is
you can smoke weed and work in the
electric vehicle plant I I don't think
this is going to go over well it's so
condescending and as you see those poles
aren't moving in fact they're going in
the wrong direction for them now you
watch the Grammys I didn't watch one
millisecond what did we miss hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else